here is Ducey once again asking Karin
jump here about the logic of this
prisoner swap in this prisoner swap why
did Russia get such a better deal
look you know I've talked about this and
I'll say this again
here were our choices our choices was uh
Britney or no one at all bringing home
one American or no American at all and
that's that National athlete we gave up
a prolific arms dealer who was convicted
of trying to kill Americans who was
called The Merchant of death the
professional athlete is also an American
citizen
so let's not forget that who deserved
and so and
he's so inept in smug look again as I
said without glibness or sarcasm it's
good to get American back but you know
if you start making trades that are
completely asymmetrical whether you're a
sports team or a nation trading a
terrorist for dead bodies or an arms
dealer for a wnb player the asymmetry of
that creates a situation where the other
country they go boy look what we can get
back
we can get our freaking crazed Merchant
of death arms dealer we can get him back
all we had to do was hijack this WNBA
player that nobody cares about this is a
problem it's just that's just a problem
of international relations she's
terrible absolutely terrible at her job
and she's dismissive and smug and
condescending and all of those things
and finally she just couldn't take it
anymore she left
the U.S Africa can you take a question
of the U.S Africans
why is it so hard to take a question on
the U.S Africa Summit when the president
has been 50 African leaders the biggest
garden of leaders of his administration
where is it hard for you to give me a
question it is not hard I've answered
would you let me answer the question or
are you okay okay I'm trying to answer
your question go ahead sir go ahead I
just tried you wouldn't let me go ahead
I just tried and you would not let me
sir so your colleague is going to ask a
question go ahead no I just I literally
just tried to answer your question you
shut me down so now your colleague is
gonna
be okay I'll see you tomorrow yeah
a good not a good day at the office for
Corinne Jean-Pierre